Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to use OpenAI’s
new language model AI to get it to
write our homework essays for us, see
how well it does that, and get this,
we will even ask it to write some computer
code for us. And it gets even better,
it does all this for free! But not in the way
you think. You will find out in a moment why.
Now, let’s see. First, we write, “When I
was young, I only liked to p”. And then,
let’s say something comes here between, and
then, “and that’s how first I got interested in
AI research.” Now we ask the AI to fill in the
middle part. Let’s see what happens together.
This indeed filled in the middle. It says,
when I was young, I only liked to play
video games. I would play sometimes more
than 13 hours per day. The rush, novelty,
and variety were beyond anything real life
could offer. (Whoa, hold it right there,
little AI!) It continues - I loved the
challenge and I excelled at it. I would
often skip classes and go to and that’s
how first I got interested in AI research.
But there is a problem. Did you notice the
problem? Yes, the video game addiction is
kind of a problem. But, that’s not what
I meant. It gets worse. Grammatically,
it kind of connects to the suffix, the text
that comes after, it is not nearly perfect,
but, perhaps the worst thing is that there
is no logical connection between them. It
does not explain how we ended up being an AI
researcher. Although Demis Hassabis, the CEO of
the DeepMind AI lab often says in interviews that
he played a ton of video games back in his day,
so this AI may be up to something. But
this new method can do way better. Look.
“When I was young, I only liked to play video
games. Over time, I started thinking if it’d be
possible to make bots to play better than any
human can ever play these games. I eventually
decided I liked working on the latter more than
playing the games themselves and that’s how first
I got interested in AI research.” Now that’s
a scholarly completion! Excellent. Loving it.
And, it has more absolutely magical
capabilities. For instance, here,
we can start diving into our narrative
immediately by talking about Wikipedia,
and, look. If we give it some space
before it, the AI will recognize that
telling the audience what Wikipedia is is
necessary, and it does it. Really cool!
And, if we feel even lazier, we can write
the start of the story, the end of the story,
and now, off you go little AI, and you
do the hard work. Let’s read it. The
commercial diver finally thought he’d snagged
a big catch when he saw something white. But
then he quickly realized it wasn’t a fish
− he was wrangling an alligator. That is
a great story. Bravo. I made sure to look
it up, white alligators apparently exist.
And it does not stop at writing
essays. Now hold on to your papers,
because it can also write
computer code for us. Let’s see.
It can finish our code that sorts a list, computes
the average of numbers, or even performs prime
factorization. But how does it do all this?
Is this some crazy mind-reading AI? Well,
not quite. It is very good, but it does not read
our thoughts. It reads our comments. These are
not part of the computer code, these comments are
a crutch to explain what the next block of code
is about to do. And, with that, the AI knows how
it can help us out. This feels like magic. Just
imagine how much easier this makes a bunch of
coding work for us. And what incredible speedup
in productivity we can expect from techniques
like this. Mind-blowing. What a time to be alive!
But wait, of course, not even this technique is
perfect. Sometimes it just does not know when
to stop. And sometimes, it just keeps repeating
itself. Alright, we get it, little AI. Thank you!
And, there is one more feature that I loved
when reading this paper. You see, normally,
you would need to train a separate neural network
for this fill in the middle capability. However,
the coolest thing here is that it can
generate continuous text from left to right,
just like the good old GPT-3 AI and
other variants. And, at the same time,
this can also fill in the middle
without being explicitly trained
to do that. Oh yes! That’s right - we get
this amazing capability essentially for free.
So, what do you think? Does
this get your mind going? Let
me know in the comments below,
and let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!